call me dude Z this is it look at this
that is what a doozy heart looks like
there's the front label and then as you
can see we got little pictures of me and
will as as the
Crowley's on there yeah yeah here you go
dude thank you uh another thing I like
is where it says the foot oh look eight
percent alcohol but where it says the
flavor it says you don't care what it
tastes like let's do this are you ready
oh man I don't drink it's so crazy when
you don't really [__] drink yeah how
like even a tiny Symphony yeah there he
goes what do you say
is it good yeah very light very
refreshing this is [__] this is
[__] good I feel drunk already yeah
no it's immediately going to myself this
is uh I don't know how much I've sipped
out of this not very much but I'm
definitely already feeling it here's the
thing though you know when we it's
absolutely insane I I just I don't know
I guess it's because my tolerance is so
[__] low oh drunk Chad
hahaha